um thank you very much for the
introduction um yeah normally I don't
get as much time so I might be and I
speak very fast so I'll try to be a bit
slower um the agenda for today is um I
will describe more things about me and
maybe make you listen better or worse I
don't know um we're going to talk about
like what is data versioning and what
it's good for and what the hell is it
and why do we need it and if we get that
part then we're going to go like okay
okay but how and at that point we're
going to look into a project is a demo I
hope uh that many of you did um did the
in uh the setup so we can skip that uh
as fast as as we can but if not we still
going to give it some time and at the
end we're just going to go over all of
this stuff in between I will try to put
as many kind of best practices and tips
and tricks and all kind of things that
relate to machine learning especially in
relation of Technical and deployment
elements um yeah so can I ask I don't
know if you can do it on uh on Zoom can
we ask how many people here have done
the
setup or can I have experience with data
version
in well it's look like the chat is empty
so I I assume people are are are still
waking up in some places in the world
okay so let's start with me um I'm
currently the head of AI in lasso
security which is a company who does
cyber security for large language
models um i' been in I've been in
startups is in different types of uh
positions relating to machine learning
for the last 10 or so years um I am not
a Founder but a Founders engineer which
is a guy who um put all the efforts in
just like the founders but take take
none of the risk and also get doesn't
get as much of the of the winnings when
you get to that point so Founders
engineer is still very nice but I won't
get millionaire anytime soon and as I
said before I have all kind of hobbies
I'm 37 I live in the Netherlands I have
a daughter and she's still cute so so
far so
good um in this point I would love to
know who here has some experience with
Git and again I'm looking for the chat
to kind of um see any
reactions oh we
have bertil Mr Hat it's uh nice so I
guess everyone this is great statistics
everyone who answered has experience
with gate but just for the sake of
completeness let's understand uh the
shortest most clean
explanations ever done on git I hope so
when you code when you work you have
your file system just the things you do
then you can upload it to kind of a
staging area by adding it and then when
you are happy with it you commit it and
now it's a part of your project and you
can revert it with restore commands and
if you want to you can go and take the
original um the original code or
anything you have that was sitting in
your repository by checking it out and
you can push and pull from the cloud to
kind of get um to kind of sync with
other people's work and put it on the
cloud and so on and well it does a lot
of other things but uh one of them is uh
diff you can look at what you did before
and kind of compare to know what uh
what's going on and the differences and
it helps you to do all kind of magical
stuff now if you've
never had used gate or you you're very
new to to program in this is going to be
a very difficult workshop and that's
fine like um if if if this is not
something you're very comfortable with
just adding committing
pulling then this is not the workshop
for you yet and you're welcome to keep
uh use the recording later on when it
makes more
sense now there is an inherit problem
within git which is uh let's say you are
a developer and you're working on this
file let's say it's a movie and every
time you edit it and you cut a bit and
you add a bit you make small changes to
it in the background get saves the
history of what your file was before as
a result for every change you have a
full copy of your of your file as is
with text file it's not really an issue
but when you talk about images and
movies and so on you can get to a point
that with the many changes to your files
your history is getting huge and then
your boss is cloning your project and
his computer
explodes in reality G just doesn't let
you do any of that it just doesn't let
you add and commit and and push big
files it just blocks it because it
doesn't want your boss to fire you for
making his computer
explode so what do we
do we use blob stores you just have a
bunch of in this case this is an S3 with
not fake names and we just you just have
a lot of locations that are very
resilient and you can easily upload and
download and it's safe and it's very
cheap to um to keep the data there
whatever you need is very easy to upload
and download in big scales and volumes
and so on and in our context when we
talk about machine learning then you can
think about it that you might have a few
project that you're doing within your
company and then then for each project
you might have a few different
environments and each environment might
also have like different uh stages of
the data so phases of it and then for
each one of them you might do different
models as you develop and for each model
you actually might do a few experiments
that might be relate to that model on
that data for that project which you
also want to monitor when that that
specific model is running in production
or running in an experiment you want to
know what is the prediction that it does
does and you want to relate to it and
also you have the other logs that the
app has that sometimes is relevant to
how your server is is working because
the predictions is part of the server
sometimes fall on the mlops or the
machine Engineers because he knows
what's the inputs and the outputs and
there might be other assets like images
or in or like uh Vector index or other
files that you also want to make sure
that are up to date with the model that
you are currently using and it can get
out of
hand now
that's not even the only part of it this
is just having it in a place where you
can store it you still want to be able
to know which model is in production
what code and what parameters that model
is using what was the one that we were
using last week if I want to train the
model again because the EU decided we
cannot no longer use data that comes
from Russia so from now on you need to
adjust your models so how do you take
that model and remove that specific data
or even answer does the data use Russian
uh input um yeah so uh on top of it when
you have the mo the monitorings there is
a lot of time disconnect or you just pay
for another platform to do it for you to
monitor over there but then you need to
manage like your relationship with that
platform and obviously the costs and um
and the learning curves and so on and if
you have multiple models you want to
track what was the parameters maybe it's
because you got more data it was is it
the algorithm is it the feature
engineering there is a lot of things to
consider that you want to be on top of
and they're sitting on different places
in in your in your bucket and even when
you want to revert you want to know
where the model is that you want to
revert and why and so on
so often enough data scientists are sad
and um this is
overly well it's it's actually not
overly complicated this is a standard
solution nothing here is special you you
you build your code and you save it on
git and then you do some pre-processing
and you clean the data and you sometimes
keep it in another place as an
intermediary result then you do training
and some of the data goes and you run a
bunch of experiments and all the
experiments you save the models at
someplace and the best model maybe go to
production and the other ones will saved
as backups in case you need to revert
because stuff can happen and your'll
server is send sending the monitoring
data to a different place where your
data scientist not your machine learning
engineer or your machine learning guy
who solved that problem he goes to that
place and he brings the data and he
writes his own kind of code and it might
be completely unrelated although it goes
about the same models and about the same
data and problems so there is a lot of
common knowledge that is lost or turns
into friction between teams and then
when it's the monitoring data there you
have offline and online experiments you
need to write this code so that also
goes into giab and maybe you want to do
some alerts if you if the predictions
all of a are all zeros or make no sense
or the data drifting and you get that
whatever distribution you had on the
model originally is not what you see now
in production you want to have an alert
so you can react so maybe you can
retrain and so on and this is just
normal this is just what you do you just
figure all of this out and you write all
this code and you use some platforms
from for some stuff and you figure it
out which is uh
difficult
so what is data
versioning you just check out a version
of a Model A tag a branch and the data
is there your monitoring is there the uh
experiment tracking the code for the
inference the code for the training um
everything you need is now at your hands
available for you to
work that's it you don't need to keep
track the files that are here are the
files that you train for the model and
if you want to train a different model
then you get the right files but then
you just commit them like any other file
the data versioning and in our case we
use it for a lot of different things
besides data it's just about having
everything just handled by git in the
same way you can version it you can much
easier break your data delete a file
restore it get it back download it you
can always you can feel way more
comfortable I know of so many people who
just take their data and they want to do
some change so they copy it to their
desktop and then they do the changes
they want and then if something is wrong
or whatever they need to bring it back
or they need to just they find a place
on S3 or the whatever blob blob store
they are sitting on and they putting it
there and they're coming back
so you have to kind of take all of those
things into consideration and why just
do the change and commit it or restore
it like any other thing be great same
with logs same with tracking of machine
learning same for your model you just
broke the model because you did the test
you override it okay it's fine and it
also includes for your infant server
sometimes that's not done by the same
machine learning engineer who build the
model or design the model but often
enough it is because there are so many
similarities in the knowledge necessary
because the guy who work with the model
can tell what is the RO data how it
looks like it can tell what the server
need to do on the way and build nice
pipelines and so on that's what data
version in is and um it's
nice so okay we got to this point where
um if you have any comments I can see
them here so write them down so I can
react to them I would like it to be as
interactive as possible this part is a
bit
um obviously I'm talking a lot because
it's my workshop but I would like you to
have questions and if you have anything
you want to share just put it on and I
will say it as well so it will be
recorded in the internet
forever so I was working for a Zab for a
data version in company before I became
the head of AI in lasso and I was
working on this framework that kind of
figure a lot of the things out and and
help you kind of manage all the new
possibilities data version was there for
a long time but it is a pretty Niche
tool that most people do not use so I
wrote this article and you can see here
that I added it to look like I got 2.4
million claps and we're going to also
look into a demo project where
everything is implemented and we going
to go and have a look how it looks like
and what it means in actual
project and at the end we going to have
everyone here is going to have just a
bunch of commands where we can kind of
play with all the automations and the
things we need to make it
work for uh tracking we're going to use
mlflow now if you have never uh used
mlflow it's one of the more popular
tools for um for machine learning
experiment tracking and it has also all
kind of versioning of models as well I
don't know if it's my favorite but it's
very popular and it more it works very
well with all
um with all data version in tools
because it makes a lot of
files so the
concept that is the biggest part that
we're going to deal with is about how to
actually use branches and tags
accordingly to kind of be on top of
everything that's the main port a main
point of this workshop and if you take
only one thing that can be a thing we're
going to work in in a in a common
workflow where you try to always merge
kind of to Dev and only from Dev to prod
which is pretty standard and we're going
to we want to use many of the G standard
tooling and standard workflows but in
general it's just about how we manage it
there isn't a lot of proprietary tooling
and and and crazy ideas some of it is is
a bit creative but most of it is very
standard it's just me trying to develop
a bunch of different project and deploy
them and see what works and what's not
so at this point we're going to a for
data version we're going to start
getting the project up so uh we're going
to use Zab but everything that I'm doing
here you could also uh use DVC which is
a very popular data version in tool and
I don't think everything can be done
with lfs which is the second most
popular tool or other um data who have
uh data that also have good capabilities
but you can definitely integrate those
ideas to all of those specifically here
I'm still an advocate at Spirit at at
Zab and I think it's a great example of
how to do it better in a sense that
everything is just been done behind the
scene and you don't do too much you
don't have to manage files directly and
do a lot of work you just work with G
normally so at this point we're going to
go into a setup and this is the
ugliest uh slide in the whole deck
and that's the fault of the people who
didn't do it yet so I'm going to give a
few minutes for people who haven't uh
been set up before what we want to do is
we want to sign in which is you can just
use your GitHub uh account or just um
any other um sign up that they have
there and then install the CLI there is
the instructions it's yeah you just get
uh you have three options and you you
choose them and you press and you double
tap on it and install then we're going
to create a token and kind of
authenticate and that will take care of
all the
permissions um you can go on the website
following those instructions but you can
also just take this shortcut because it
actually works for every
user then you're going to when you
create a new token you're going to get
this line it will have the actual values
and you just run it on the terminal
where you're going to
work following that you can duplicate
and clone so duplicate is is just a
version you can go to to my to this
project to this demo project and
duplicate is sort of like fork and
change ownership so it's the the origin
is yourself you don't go back to my
project so you can do all the changes
and it just becomes your project uh
forever and then you can clone it your
username is going to be here and when
it's clone you can CD in and set up your
virtual environment install the
requirements and this Al is just make
all the CLI things look a bit better and
at the end if you run demo and this is
this is two dashes to dash help and you
see the help then you know everything is
okay now in this point I'm going to give
you a few minutes to to do it and for
the people who already did it I'm going
to give you uh
this okay um I don't see a lot of
reaction so I assume everything went
well and everyone is already on board
and if you're not then you can still do
it later it's fine
um okay so we saw a lot of funny babies
critical for um for any good
presentation so we go back we want to
see branches and tags and here we're
going to go straight into the code and
the examples and we're going to go from
one to the other to kind of understand
uh what want
do so let's start with the main branch
often enough we use the main branch uh
just for uh we use it for to the latest
version of all of our code and the thein
the accumulation of everything we did so
far but this is not what we want to do
in our data science machine learning
project we're actually going to use it
for docs for a place to kind of have
discussions and understanding the
business problems the dat we get how we
collected dat come the require the
requirements we have this is the place
for collaboration this is the place for
documentations for um you can also use
this place for tracking of experiments
so you can go there and kind of see the
the experiments we're going to go and
talk about it a bit later but you don't
have to and it's a very kind of empty
basic place that anyone can just
download and kind of figure out what the
project is about and the discussions are
there so I'm going to move into my uh
code and let's see that this is
working so let me see can you see my uh
my code so this is a pretty um pretty
nice example this is mostly rme all the
other folders you see on the side uh are
there just because um I wanted the help
to just work so uh St is just a shortcut
for G status so I I you can look here at
all the files and and the main thing is
this thing doesn't um there are this
thing doesn't need to work in theory in
the in the main branch so but what you
would like to have so this is an
overview of all the branches we're going
to have and all the branches we're going
to discuss we are now just in the main
branch
and there is nothing you need to do here
I I left here the instructions for the
installation and the setup just in case
but what I would which you might also
want for your project how to install how
to how to get all the packages which
Technologies you use and so on and you
want to put information about your data
and the problem you have so in this case
I took a standard diabetes data sets
that you can get from Psychic learn this
talk is not going to be um it's not
going to be very focused on the actual
machine learning uh aspect but on the
solution architecture of the code of the
solution architecture of everything
around it and how you would put
everything together you can build better
models uh probably with another 10
minutes of concentrating on that exact
thing so here I describe the size of the
data which might be able to change but
where you how you collect it what it
means the features what they mean and so
on and which evaluation you want so here
I decided of a root mean square error
because it's a regression problem or
this are we going to address it as a
regression uh problem and we can have a
discussion here of what we need and why
is this one better or another metric can
be better and there is a small
distribution here you can find about how
your data
distributed doesn't need to have too
much but it's just a place to kind of
bring everyone on
board any questions about the main
Branch probably
look no perfect so I'm going to change
back into the into the slides to
consider our next one which is yeah what
I just said we're going to have the data
set and the examples I wonder why there
is such a big blank in the middle of of
the slide that doesn't look like me I
know how to use all the space in the
slides and have a small place for my
head at the
bottom so let's talk about data branches
now those are very interesting for what
we want because it's one of the examples
of how we diverge from just any other
project so normally you have do you have
your um data probably in a specific the
data in a specific bucket that is the
data bucket for your company or the data
or the specific project data bucket that
you have and you might have different
kind of phes for it this is the same but
what we're going to do we're just going
to have it as branches so you just set
it up to have a branch instead of just
having and that's kind of managing both
the upload and download and all these
aspects of the data but also the
relationship between them so all the
data comes in and it goes into raw and
if you can take one tip that is related
to this kind of view of your data always
up upload to raw and from raw do all the
transformation changes to other places
so you don't you if you start changing
raw you kind of lose um you you lose the
linearity and you also commit yourself
to kind of working from a specific phase
of raw it's much nicer to Raw is just
where you upload everything and then if
you do a change or you split or you do
any kind of processing you put it on a
different branch at the end and we're
going to look on how you move things
around it depends on the technology but
in general it's just like copy files and
and so you can obviously do it with any
kind of integration like with with spark
or any kind of batch jobs and so on it's
not uniquely special you just apply it
and you just commit it to a branch and
not just uploading to a certain
location now
um what it gives you one of the best
benefits is that it takes those very
unclear very complicated long kind of
addresses which is the way we manage the
actual data this data belong to this
environment on this project on this
version on this date on this aspect on
this algorithm on this date this is
where the model is it just turns it into
the sing the only model you have locally
and the only model you have for that use
case so all the addresses becomes very
easy also on your server side when you
want to load things or when you want to
manage them and hopefully we're going to
have some time to look at data analysis
where we just take mod from any branch
and just use it to to do an analysis
without getting too complicated about it
now um I like this idea of put in like
data that you see as you upload it to
raw and you see it's broken you can just
get it to corrupted and you can make
those automations uh later on it's the
same ETL operations you would have done
anyway but now it just sits in a place
that you can always address it and if
you want to change your workflow you did
one type of split and now you want to
have a different split or you want to
first um clean it and then split it it's
very easy to go to raw and just create a
new Branch from raw do the changes you
need on on the new branch and set the
automation to go there in the new way
and the code that does the automation
can sit on the new Branch the code that
does the ETL is sitting on the data
Branch so branches are also free so you
just make one for Dev one for everyone
you can you can run it you can develop
on it it's really nice um and you don't
need to feel shy about it now there's an
important aspect here which is data copy
an inherent uh feature of all data
version in tools is a file the
duplication if you have the same file in
different branches or different
locations it will not make a copy it
will only save a link to that place and
that is extremely important when you do
a branch you don't want to pay for
copies for everything which you often do
in the original way when you have this
project and then another project to use
similar data you copy everything or if
you don't copy you have to manage the
addresses of the old one and then if you
change that then your new project is
broken so often enough you copy and
maybe you do process but not everything
is processed or you add some new uh
features and so on you get a lot of
duplication of data which you pay for
it's not the most expensive but it can
get out of hand pretty easily now um an
extra feature is a file the duplic
dation or chunk duplication specifically
where if you have a file and you make it
bigger and bigger and bigger then in
that case um only the added is changed
just like any other change you only pay
for the extras and the chunks are
managed as as
um as pointers and that gives you a lot
of benefits in in use cases where you do
train and test splits for example you
don't pay for the train and test again
as new data because it's the same chunks
of the original data so you can have
your file and the train and the test and
everything but you actually pay for
every chunk once and it's great when you
add extra extra features often enough
it's something you either do in a lazy
evaluation manner so you don't have to
pay for it but then you pay for it for
um in inference time which again it's a
it's something to consider when you work
with big data but otherwise it's just
great that you add new columns and you
don't pay um on having everything
together you don't have to make one file
for this and one file for this and so on
so it can save you a lot of work it also
was very helpful uh as kind of a cheat
when I do a monitoring I'm just
uploading I'm extending the file and I'm
just uploading again knowing that behind
the scene the chunin is's going to take
care of everything it's only going to
upload the new chunks so I don't
actually need to go like oh the last row
I uploaded was row 100 so now I want to
upload from 100 forward you know like
it's taking care you in an efficient way
it uploaded in a very efficient way and
so on so chunk the duplication is a
great feature for machine learning um
and we can rely on it uh whenever we
have a lot of situations where we it
feels like you create copies but you
actually uh
don't yeah this is the main tip of the
day always upload to
Raw so how does it look like you have
your data branches and when you check
out the the data folder in this I like
to put the data in data because it's
data and so put data in your data makes
sense and you can either check it out or
just use a CLI now and what happens just
you get the new files so you can think
about it that behind the scene um the
server or wherever it is it uploaded
data and now the data is committed to
that Branch so the branch which is kind
of like the same place as your bucket
has more file
when you check out you get the new you
get the new files and in many many
toolings you also have like a CLI like a
copy or other tooling that you can do in
zup is Set uh Z copy or CP kind of like
normal copy um and that kind of makes
sure that you can always get the latest
version of the data very easily and if
there is other flows and other elements
that are behind the scene the data
scientists get way less pain and doesn't
need to concentrate about those aspects
you just if something happened and
someone figure it out then whatever data
you get when you check out you're going
to have that new data and it it helps
you again it helps you to manage you can
also manage it with a database where you
have a database and every time you kind
of do it in chunks because if you do it
all at once then your database is too
busy working for your requests now it's
very to create dumps and give you all
the data and Export so often enough you
you want to you rather do it in chunks
than enough and then and then you need
to remember which one you were the last
one you did which you can also do in a
database or you can also check your
files and figure out what was the latest
and then make a query that adjust those
times to get it so this is just simpler
you just check out and if the guy just
uploaded to the branch this is taking
care for you now it's one of the nice
benefits right let's go and look at data
branches so changing back into the
coding slides
oops oh
no can you see me
again no let's I think it
disappeared let's hope everything is
okay or I'll have to go back into kind
of um oh no it is it is
okay setup here is challenges so you can
see now you can see my code so I will
just check out the raw Branch so again I
have a shortcut because I do a lot of
this kid stuff so it's just check out
into raw and now um there is there were
updated in the RW that I didn't see
um
wa I think we are missing some of the
images so materialization is when you
have a file and it's just the pointer
before I did this thing all the images
were just pointer it doesn't download
them unnecessarily only if you need them
so in this case I materialize it to so
we can look at the r me so this is my RO
Branch all the code I have here the the
only relevant part I can delete the
other ones but again I don't want to
ruin the CLI for this demo but I just
have like a data kind of
object and it's just a helper that
manage a lot those elements so behind
the scene uh this is how I get the
original dat data and I can just do um
and I implemented just doing like to add
rows and to split to which will move it
into the split so we can have a look at
how it looks like but um wait so if we
look at the at the the data I have data
and let's see how it looks like in
theory here I only have like a single
file do I have so if you can see here
make sure you can see it yeah there's
only single f file and you can for for
the sake of this example this is our
source of origin this is where the
server just uploading all the data here
and there is a single file and that file
is it can get bigger and bigger so I can
go and do something like um this is how
it looks like I can do demo data adds
and add a bunch of
rows and um now what actually happened
is I just sample a bunch of rows and
appended them again for a toy example so
you can look at the Ed RS
function and this is how you do it with
uh Zab it's implemented of uh FS spec
which is kind of a tooling for a lot for
working also with Google cloud and S3
and a zoo bucket and so on and I just
read straight from again my location at
the raw Branch the data file I just read
it like it's any other place and this is
something that's very easy to manage and
these things are just set but kind of
automatic so here you can have this as a
constant but uh for the sake of it it's
just fine so you just read it I sample a
few more rows I edit and I just just
write it back into the same file so now
the now the file is just 100 rows uh
bigger now um this thing actually wrote
it into the cloud so now I actually
locally because this can be run anywhere
this can run on a Lambda this can run on
a server anyone can add data to the
server I don't have it currently so I
need to do a g
pull let's see if I need to
[Music]
do and it looks at it and it's angry
with me because it's a
demo but yeah I just added a bunch of
rows and dels and it's the same file at
this moment but the but the point of it
I just pulled it and I got the latest
version and maybe I'll get a better time
if I'll just do it again
now this is the ra branch and we should
all the files should be uploaded here
it's another thing silly thing I'm also
looking to see that the change was the
last one this is for me for the buug in
and now if I do get
pool I get the new
data
yeah
yeah so yeah just got uh more data this
is a way to work with it and again if
you want to do some analysis you can
just look you just check out the raw
branch and now you have all the files
and they sit there and you can run some
analysis if you want to just look at
things or build some automations from
the from the raw uh file uh to another
one so um so let's go into the Split
Branch now Split Branch is a pretty
weird name for for a branch but I felt
like for a demo sake it it it works and
here what we got is all of a sudden we
just have the files here they just
arrived so again I don't need to bring
and download I checked out the branch I
wanted and the data just waiting for me
split now again this is there is um a
small tip for machine learning Engineers
is that you might want to consider uh
the benefit of having the split as part
of your branch and not being like run as
with a random seat which is constant or
that is decided uh on training time is
that if you're collaborating as a big
team you're all working on the same
place so you're all starting from the
same split you know that your models and
the different er uh training jobs you do
they all working on the same uh ground
they're all evaluated based on the same
data so you you're saving a lot of
friction and problems you might have
with that so it's a benefit um the
alternative is that you can also just
run the the split in on the fly at
training time and it might be again if
you're using big data and you you're
smart about the way you do the it Lazer
which you can do where you split it and
then you just read lazily just the data
you need it can be more efficient but
then you are more susceptible for bugs
and issues with collaboration and so on
any
questions
yeah very thank you thank you Mr hatut
have a nice
day okay then this is the H Split Branch
and again here um just if you want to
have a look I can do demo and data
split and now because now we're talking
this I run it here but again I'm
simulating a server running it as ATL
behind the scene so so behind the scene
when I do the
split what would actually happen
oops is that I will look into the data
the latest version right because this is
the latest of the raw and then I do a
new split and this is a very common
again another tip for machine learning
Engineers you want to have a train and
and then the test you split into
validation and test and you only use the
test set once and you can use the
validation test for all kind of hyper
parameter optimizations but the moment
you start using the test file again and
again you kind of you kind of cheat
yourself because you get to a point
where you start start optimizing
yourself to the test it so you want to
use train validation and test and then I
just save them straight into the cloud
so now again the data is in the cloud I
don't have it locally this is all
running behind the scene and I'm walking
and I'm very happy so I need to go back
into my system and do git pool and
hopefully I will see the changes
yep I got the new the new rows for each
of them and there are some parameters
here so everything everything in the in
this demo has is using the great typer
Library so you can do help on it and
kind of see uh what are the different
option the test sides and the seed if
you want to run an experiment with other
elements of how you it could in theory
run and also to debug
yourself so this is our H data branches
and if there is no other questions
which I don't see it's only my questions
then um well I have a lot of questions
so let's go back into our slides and
consider the second the next
part so can you see my slides I don't
think
[Music]
so yes so this is the developer branches
those are the more interesting ones that
we are using all of your code is
actually is written here and we have two
types of those you have active branches
or active Branch this is a branch you
never delete you always keep it and it's
kind of like your if you are a software
engineer you often do it you have a Dev
environment where you put all your
nonsense in and then you have a stage in
and a prod I skip the stage in in this
case you can have it but in general uh
you just everything is ending up at Dev
you see that it works the way you want
it and then when you're happy with it
you send it to pod and pod only gets
from Dev and it it saves you a lot of
issues with mergin and some other
elements now you can also have feature
branches this is another standard of uh
of git when I can develop a specific
model and I start in this example we're
going to go with we start with a
baseline model which is just getting the
average and always predict the average
and there are a lot of benefits of of
doing it cuz you get a good Baseline of
your problem you can evaluate it all
your other models next to it it's much
easier to develop and it gives you the
space to develop other things you would
want early on but don't prioritize often
which is uh model monitoring and model
tracking and other elements you do all
of those and you just put a very very
simple Baseline model so and those ones
you can delete them
afterwards you you you don't need to get
married to any of those ones they are
not active branches the feature
branches now it's very important in my
opinion to only code in Dev it's kind of
like you don't want to code in prod in
in normal soft in standard stand in
standard uh software engineering it's
really nice that you have everything
condensed in one place and you can
always figure it out and you can play
with it without breaking any other
systems by accident so just just code in
Dev now an extra layer of it is the use
of tags and this is something I'm a big
fan of is um let's maybe talk about kind
of git labels so the head where you are
now is a label of a Comm of a specific
commit Branch name is a label that moves
with you every time you commit you get a
new commit and your and the label of
that branch is moving with you and a tag
is a label that stays on that commit so
if you do any change and you commit your
tag is still showing you the latest
version so often what I like to do is
when I'm done with the model and I feel
like it's it's ready it's practically
it's working all the all my uh tests are
passing and everything I'm very happy
with it then I tag it and now even if I
delete the branch later I can always go
back to this place so if I I have some
code I forgot or I want to have a look
at or I have a bug and I want to see if
I had it there I can always go back to
that place and I I like to kind of
automate it so we're going to use it in
this case I think today there are still
not enough tooling for kind of G um data
version and stuff uh DVC have a lot of
CLI scripting that they're doing but I
think that we are still in the early
stages where people going to start using
it and start kind of have a lot of those
tooling to make those things simpler but
this is the commands that you can always
use with G to kind of tag things and
remove tags and so on and in our CLI we
also have kind of a shortcut for
it so um yeah what happened um what you
can see in this Casa another element
that is very nice for this kind of
development branches is that you can you
can maintain intermediary results so
let's say um I'm I was developing a Dev
um just a linear regression and decided
to also use PCA PCA is not a very heavy
uh computation to do but assume it's
something bigger for example uh
embedding uh to a vector of images or
text or so on then you want to you want
to do it once and kind of have it there
with you you don't want to read it again
and again redo that again and again and
again so it's really nice that you can
develop in your script that you just
after you run this you save it and you
commit the data together as to replace
the original data you don't keep one
data train one data train plus Vector
what you just skip only the train and
you just work with a single file that
makes
sense and uh yeah so let's have a look
at how it looks in our
project okay you go back to code yes
okay so in our case um hopefully there's
no issues I'm going to go into Dev uh we
can go into Dev Baseline do I don't I
don't think I deleted it yeah so this is
kind of our Baseline model
and this need to refresh
[Music]
so why aren't you doing that
yeah it's everything still working
correctly
yeah so in this case you know what I
will okay um so this is our kind of Dev
Baseline model and this is a really good
place to kind of have all the benefits
of what we talked about earlier and
maybe it's a good time to kind of look
at the General in uh software one a nice
framework or kind of a design pattern
that I'm a fan of
so obviously you can see that there is a
lot of a lot more things here I have the
file the original one as we said the
train test and
validations and we use mlflow we're
going to talk about it later which
creates this ml run folder for us where
all the all the experiments are running
H the notebooks are relevant at this
point a model is where we're going to
save the single model we have now
sometimes you might use multiple models
one uh for multi-staging models or other
elements or you have more things so I
like to put it inside the folder and the
prediction is every time I train a model
and I uh and I evaluate it on a test set
I also save that test set as well it
goes with it and I track it and later on
I can see if the model is does something
funny on the data I can just check it
out and see oh this is literally the
data that it did and this is the tag
that it had and this is the prediction
that it gave me so I can track back
where it goes so we're going to go into
it when we're going to talk about
Stables but here about stable H stable
branches but here what we can already
looking is to kind of like the way of
looking at at um a very standard kind of
way of deploying models so in this case
I implemented a a minan regressor and
I'm a big fan of using um like the pyit
learn kind of wrapp it around it to make
sure that the fit and the predict and
everything is implemented the way I
would like it and if I want to have
optimizations I can do it here and uh
the trainer it depends again on the
scale but in this case it'll be it's
just the the object that kind of manage
all the training aspects it knows all
the parameters it does the evaluation I
don't need all of this to do predictions
in production I but I would like it to
kind of manage everything around it so
the interesting part about it is
something like our fit function and this
is where we look at the ml flow and
mlflow I give it all the parameters that
I think is relevant and in the real
production and uh setup I will have a
lot of things that I will care about
here and I take this data again this is
not very efficient in in this is not how
I would do it if I had really big data
but I'm I'm giving myself um a bit of an
easy out and I I create one version of
uh with the splits well it just it just
read them from local because again if I
want to have them I just pull and I have
the most recent uh data which hopefully
we should be able to do so um oh sorry
get
pull yeah so it already has the latest
version and um then I run in one
experiment and then I have and then I
retrain on the entire data set that now
this is another great design pattern
that a lot of people don't do but
sometimes you train and you do all kind
of um you do a train test validation or
kind of a different splits and at the
end you take the best model or one of
the models and you use that one but in
actuality you probably do want to have
to use the one that goes into production
you want to have all the data trained on
so it has the most amount of information
it can do the best kind of get you the
best results in production where we
going to monitor on what it's doing so
even though I train the model once here
and this experiment is actually not very
sophistic is obviously pretty easy I
just go I I fit the estimator which is
exactly what you think it is I just fit
it with the DAT data it ignores anyway
it just counts what is the average and
just keep that
value and after I train it I create a
prediction and the reason I added it
which is also why um it's you'll get a
bug if you do changes to this thing
um H and then afterwards you're trying
to create the old data thing because
you're going to have one more column on
this one but in this case I can go I can
evaluate it and then I
can um log the results of the evaluation
and also log all the predictions and
that is how later on if I have issues I
can go back and and see wait when I
evaluated the model why did I go I did
so well and I can find out that maybe
the data I use was very biased or maybe
my model got a look into uh there was
Data leakage and the model got to look
into Data it shouldn't have because this
test I was training here or something
like you it helps you to kind of always
be on top of things even when you go
back into them like kind of good
documentation does and we have this tag
which we're going to talk about in a
second which I always add another
element that kind of pin me to a certain
point now there isn't too much more um
at the end uh you can save the model and
I
implemented um that we save the our
predictor into into a file so you just
make sure that there is a folder there
and you save it another aspect of it is
the predictor class now this is a class
I'm a big fan of not specifically the
predictor but the idea of having a
wrapper that has your prediction model
and also all your metadata in production
I'm almost always don't do predict but I
do a transform and the reason is is that
when I get a prediction even if it's a
single one but again if you want to
scale it you can send predictions as a
list or as a j Json of an of Records or
key with a value of arrays and at the
end you can do predictions of a lot of
them in parallel but I would like when I
monitor to be on top of all of these
different elements so I don't want just
to know what data I had which is my X
and what prediction I give but when how
long would it take me to give it maybe
my model is too slow what time it was so
of course I would like that thing to to
be on top of it and other element that
are relevant where can I find that Motel
later so we're going to go over the rest
of them uh how we we use them later but
this idea of using transform and then on
the server side the server what it does
and this is a very classic fast API
server
so this is a standard way to do it where
you have a models and you manage the
life cycle of the model where find it
the life cycle with this element this is
kind of more latest version of well I
don't know when you're going to watch
this um talk but currently it's pretty
uh latest uh way to do it spelling and
um you want to make sure that you have a
place to write the monitors and then you
load the model which is just putting it
inside this model uh tooling now in fast
API it's very nice to have kind of Base
models or tools that give you it gives
you a lot of it gives you automatic um
um documentation it does some
validations for you it throw the right
erors for you it's great you really want
it and you make an example here and when
the loading the model is literally just
loading it um from wherever I saved it
earlier and then during prediction I
just go transform form the reason I have
this predicting we should be model
transform actually the reason I have it
here separately from the actual server
which is this app predict is that I
would like to first uh I get the
predictions I send the task to the
background to log those and it adds
behind the scene and any now and then
it's going to upload that CSV behind the
scene and um at the end I just take the
the the latest uh prediction and I just
take that one so I I can I I don't have
to um so I don't have to send back to
the to whoever did the query all the
information I just I still want to log
it an alternative that you can do here
is to use something like log Guru and
save it into a file in a structured way
where you actually take this turn this
into a Json and you make maybe a nice
delimiter and then you log it with the
delimiter and then the Json and then you
can look afterwards in the text file
just find those things you can make make
your own special um uh it's a bit out of
the on the scope of this one but you can
make instead of you have info and debug
you can make another kind of uh level of
let's say monitoring and then you filter
by monitoring and you take every row and
you just split it and get immediately
your data in a structured way so it's
really nice and it would work with most
platforms that because they all have
logs and this is the serve again it just
it just runs unicorn
um something I got used to do way more
often than I had to when I was working
zup there are extremely talented
developers and you see them do magic
stuff all the time and you start using
bash bash more often than you would
imagine here is a little um special case
of Zab Zab has a feature called Mount
and that's kind of It's a lazy
evaluation so when I use this thing
let's say I want to check any model I
want if I use Mount then even if I can
have in my data set set a lot of data
and pens model and and a lot of other
elements and tests that I don't use it's
not going to bring them on it's just
going to bring the data that just the
model file that I need just the code
file that I need it only going to have
the relevant stuff so it's just very
efficient uh all the benefits of lazy
evaluation and that's kind of how we do
the sve now um
let's try it and see now the demon of of
um the demon of of um as the demon of
demos and he's going to be here so we're
going to have uh I'm going to run the
train and again at this
point we can have a look what we have
and we just I can add a description and
a tag and the tag we're going to talk
about in a second but I can run
it and this is me just testing
everything this is not going to go to
production this is not ready to be
anything yet it's just me see that
everything
working and this is a small feature I
made where where because I know at
training I save for the model which was
the LA what was the commit in the in the
latest split I go to the remote split
and check what was the changes there so
I can tell and in this case there was a
change so we download the new data and
it crashes because um that's how it
works with
demos and then it runs the test that's
another important uh thing to do people
think that in data science we don't do
tests but we're going to show them so if
I do test I check all this is for the
data elements and for my trainer I check
that it goes I check the artifacts are
created I check the predictions are nice
I didn't I didn't check that the
predictions are nice but I check that I
got an evaluation and then I got a
predictor it's good start because my
server actually is going to check that I
can predict it that all the things I
care about exist and I can check the
server as a server to simulate it and
run it locally with the input which I
already have the example because I've
implemented it as a server so I can
check it out and see that it works so
very nice and this element is going to
go into monitoring we're going to
discuss it in a second is it going to be
thingy okay it commit a
merge raining so this is another short
cut by omes if you want to check it out
later but I just do lot of the uh other
elements and if wait we can actually
look into just like our day of model
this is might for the sake of it could
have just called it Dev but
um um this is where always uh I always
merge the latest version of my models
and again we just added rows so I get
them and I can do I probably should do
that uh when you pull a data in the
strategy of the merge should be theirs
so it always get the latest so this is
another hack which I should implement it
public so now this model is more
sophisticated because if we're going
back into what we discussed
earlier um we are now just looked into
the dev Baseline but I simulated this
entire thing yesterday so I I
implemented all the different ones so
you go here and then you implement the
Dave linear regression and then you
implement this one and I think this one
should be an xgo model so yeah so this
one is the latest version from the XG
boost version with the PCA and all the
fun things around it so before we look
into it and what it means to be training
let's look to where the tag is are and
where the prod kind of um branches are
sitting
up actually I knew I would never have
enough time just not who I
am but as I said I think in the
introduction it's going to be way overly
um comprehensive so when you follow this
we just talked about it you can save the
elements and we can check it out in a
second and and then when we're done and
we are happy with it we merge the code
the model everything we need we merge it
kind of from Dev to p and the this is
where you can only pull data run the
training the test and commit everything
and tag it so there's no there is you
don't write code here but you still
create a new file for the for the for
the model and if you have more file that
you just uploaded in the cloud then when
you pull it you can retrain here again
and again and again so the cycling of
retraining with new data is
automatically kind of set up for you you
don't really need to be worri about it
you just make sure that the
implementation works and then every time
that there is a new data is coming in
and the split has new data then the the
prod will have it with it and this can
create more and more Brad
models so the way it would look if if
I'll run it in a second is that when you
do dash dash tag it will check if you
need to bring data and then if there is
no uh it will check what is the latest
tag that exists in remote if it's prod
two it knows that prod 3 is next in line
and because of it we're going to use it
and we save it as a parameter uh during
our training and at the end we're going
to tag it because I want to collect
everything commit it and then tag that
commit so anytime I want to get to this
model and check where it is I have the
right tag for it now mlflow by itself
Auto automatically create for each
experiment it creates a folder and for
each experiment it has a bunch of runs
and for each runs it saves a lot of
different
files and I'm going to move here a bit
more steps so we can see how it looks
like in one go with the
monitoring uh but this is this is the
trick I showed you before I can check
what was the what was the latest version
of the data in the Split Branch CU if
the split didn't change there is no
reason to pull the data there is no
reason to do anything copies now file
duplication will save me from doing it
but it will take the time to evaluate it
and it's a
shame again depends some toing will just
know not to do anything but um it's just
a nice hack to
have and it's very important the same P
tests I run for testing I run them as
I'm running the training I will not
upload something that doesn't pass my
training I will not share it I will not
I I will fix the problems and then I
don't if if I have this why if I have a
prod three file and it doesn't work the
P it doesn't work I will never see Logs
with that tag upstairs I will never see
logs of the locally as well well locally
I will see it but I could easily find
find out because it failed and I could
see where it failed so I don't upload if
it fails and using your P test as part
of your training it's just good best
practice I I didn't hear a lot of people
say it but from the moment I start doing
it I never
stopped um yeah it deserves another mem
so I'm going to continue here straight
to monitoring and going to go into the
demo in one go I can see we have about
20 minutes I will try to do it in 15 and
then uh leave five minutes for
questioning questions I hope you not do
questioning on me so monitoring is one
thing that most people don't get to and
when they get to it's only in a
corporation and it's it's it's something
that they Prett late so it's not as
commonly talked about besides people who
build product for those but the idea
behind it is that every time I get a
prediction I save the prediction what
the data it had which prediction it had
and what I like to do because of this
framework is to save which tags it also
held and and which data it was hold in
and which run it can have and that means
that I can use it later and we can
quickly go and have a look at how it
looks like but I can look and build data
drift kind of alerts and evaluations I
can find if a model is doing something
weird in production I can go and see all
the parameters that he that he was built
on if it's an XG boost what type of
parameters it TR all of the these
different elements I can find them from
the monitoring so everything leads to
everything what we talked about the
complexity of the other questions we
have if a model some does something in
production I can always check out that
tag and see everything which data it was
used for training which parameter it
uses um what kind of eval ation it did
which everything is there all the
constant the code the bugs everything is
in one place and I can always get from
it from anywhere to anywhere now mlflow
the way it runs and create those folders
it has a nice kind of UI you can run and
here I implemented you can run mlflow UI
and you just get the UI or demo mlflow
which will run it with a mount from the
remote so every time after I did a
training I upload it into the remote so
again it's in the cloud it's safe I
don't need to pay for any other kind of
um weight and biases or any other uh
platform it's just on my gate I have the
data and I can just directly mount it
and run those visualization and because
I save the commit I can go like oh this
commit did this good this commit did
this good and so on so it saves me a lot
of trouble and the only thing that the
reason that this is uh and this is the
most tricky but I think insightful part
of this entire idea because I figure out
which tag it's going to be before its
training and I upload it afterwards in
production that thing is going to be
Port three because this is embedded into
the model during training so in theory
you don't commit and now you know that
Port is going to point to something you
first figure out which one is the tag
you will have later
on and then you train it you add it as a
parameters like it's like any parameter
of machine learning you add also the
data commit and other things so you can
tell later on if a model is doing better
because it has more data or it has a
different data commit or it which also
apply for feature engineer and so on so
this will become more information you
can use to analyze to analyze the models
you have and then after you decided of
it and you saved it during training as
part of what you save into the model you
can push the branch and get it so um
that solves a lot of problems and and
it's uh really nice now I uh I gave a
few examples of what you can do in a
monitoring Branch like data distribution
outliers you can save there the models
for outlier detection you can save there
the code for your alerts and uh here is
a few tools we're going to look at
evidently again if we have
time
and I'll just go through it because this
is our last branch and the analysis
branch which is um again it's a place
that normally people just do it on
different project and they just do
everything in different place and you
shouldn't have to it's where you're
going to run like a forward test where
you kind of you have two models in
production we just we're going to show
how you can deploy different ones by
just changing the tag so you can serve a
specific tag it would just get that one
and only serve that one so you can put
some of your input some of your users
are going to or your infrastructure is
going to H ask the old model 1% is for
the new model you see you get the
reaction you want and and and then you
know you should update your model and
change it and then it's very uh it's not
very common but you but it's you should
definitely do it is a back test that
after you're done you actually switch it
around you move 99% of your of the
queries you send to the new model but
you still send 1% back and you want to
see the same effect in Reverse if you
don't it's a flag and you should go back
and kind of figure out what's going on
and why do you see the change or do you
what's going on so it's it's a good kind
of um a rule um rule of thumb to kind of
follow and also you want to know which
model did worse or better it's really
isy nice to be able to have a place
where you can just download all the
models and compare them and so on on
whatever specific data sets because
maybe one data was training one and one
with the other and you want to compare
them on the new data you got not on the
old one because might one of them might
have already looked into it
so um and this is again where you can
find I think that is actually not the
right uh code but this the the QR is the
is the right one so um we also have the
link in the presentation earlier so
don't look at this one this is an old
version Look at the new one with the p
data 23 now I'm going to go back into
the code and we're going to look at all
of those elements and then we're going
to
summarize
so okay we are looking the code yes so
now
uh
so we are now in the dev model and if I
do git train uh not g
demo first of all I can do like show me
all the tags that we are now holding we
holding nothing I I think this is a PCX
J boost and this is still the dev model
so this is this green one that we uh the
latest version of it so this I can still
run here test but there is no version no
current model here and what we're going
to do we're going to train it and we're
also going to tell it to tag the model
at the end now if you look um if you
look at the data currently because we
just brought it from scratch it has this
version but as I said I'm going to
persist on the first training I'm going
to persist it with the
PCA so I'm going to also and now this is
where normally things should should fly
in in because it's a demo this Should
Crash but let's
see
so in the meantime I can have a look
here on the changes that I had to my
code so I added an auto which I just
forgot to do earlier I keep all kind of
other parameters that I care about as
part of the part of the data um yeah it
has it had an issue perfect but still
still made it still passed the test so I
know it would work and and now I added
the persist so whenever I get a model
and this is a bit this is a bit of a
trickery you don't have to do it but I
kind of when I do an experiment I send
the columns and I check if the columns
exist because if they exist I don't need
to retrain the PCA I can just do
prediction on it and I know my model
already has it so um I recommend for you
to go and kind of check it out and kind
of see the trickery that is going on in
this case but again I check if there is
if the number of PCA columns make sense
and then I don't retrain let's go into
the actual place so here is the XG boost
and I check unless you force me to train
because again at the end I would like to
train on the entire data set but uh when
it's done I check if the if the new
columns exist and also they should be
the right the amount of columns that I
would like and if not I I do it from
Scotch I do a standard and PCA then exus
and I train it on the original features
and when you go back into the
training then after I did the training
and I keep the model that I want so if
you ask me to persist I can go take only
the persist part I remove the XG boost
element and I just saves the new I I
just saved the new files uh locally and
I I keep the original features I add the
the Target and I add the new uh the new
PCI features and now if I look at the
head you can see that I but it didn't
work did I tell you to
persist that's that's the real uh that's
that's what you would expect this is up
to date
interesting we did tell you to persist
right we did interesting let's have a
look at a different element of it I hope
it's we we're going to do it next time
but um you see that I I figured out
already what should be kind of the model
and then at the end I tagged at Dev
model 7 and if you would look now G tags
boy is like the one of the commit I'm
looking now so this is the this is the
commit that we have now and I can do
something like I can serve it so this
will serve this one I can also use Tag
to save any to serve any model I want so
let's just run it locally so this will
run the server and I'm too lazy but you
can you can go here and there is a
documentation on/ dos but I will just go
here and I will run like query it 50
times and it just Square it and does the
predictions and the server again you can
see behind the scene every I think 30
seconds or so it will take the most
recent kind of uh tracking information
uh for monitoring and um this file and
this is another hack use different files
to make sure when you upload to the
cloud so you don't run over one or the
other you um it's just a way to work
with kind of streaming data in a more
safe way so every time I run it I get a
new file so I I don't H make a mess over
those things and um yeah it's done
uploading and I can also do an look at
the latest the predictions when I was
talking about the monitoring and you can
see the latest one that we had this was
the Commit This was the branch was it
was train on this is the parameters I
actually have all of them but I don't
print them to screen and the tags the
data commit it was trained all the
information that is relevant for me to
kind of figure out where I stand and go
from one place to another H is here and
this is the same data that is now
running on the monitoring branch and uh
and let's go for prod so prod is the is
the latest version of this model um do
we have do we have yeah this this is on
P 7 this was the latest latest training
but I'm not I'm not afraid to try again
try tag persist and this in theory
should just work and if there is any
problem here I go back to Dev model I
fix it and I merge it back there might
be changes in this specific project
because um I there are changes in the
rmy which I I I made so you might want
to consider but if you just start in you
can just go and try to go into the data
add and data split and go into those
kind of um play with them and see that
you can always retrain and tag and
persist there is a bug here
because
F I'm not sure where this file is but um
I think I said too many good words on on
mlflow so they they came they came after
me which is not surprising if you know
the
guys okay I will use the next three
minutes to just show the other uh
relevant
branches and it's pushing the branch all
this main thing all the code of the logs
uh of of the logging is just like
sitting here so this is what it prints
at the beginning and uh I made this so
it would be easier to look and all the
documentation or kind of the help you
have is written in here so all the logic
and the stuff are here and um you can uh
go for example let's go into the train
one that we saw it's kind of what you
expect I'm trying to pull the data this
will not pull if it shouldn't because it
checks the model I have locally if the
commit that it had did the remote at the
time of training is the same one and
then I just run a fit I run the same
parameters we had before um I I'm I'm a
big fan I don't know if I said it
already but having all the configuration
in a single place so even things that I
need a bit of logic or other way to get
like I just put all of them kind of
special constants sitting like this and
I just have all the constants of all the
apps sitting in one place it's very easy
to kind of be on top of what's going on
and to know where to look when you have
different changes so I'm a big fan of
it so we do the training then I run the
same pie test that we ran before we see
that it passes or we stop if everything
is okay and also it's another validation
the predictor is okay we upload uh the
tracking information so we can find it
later and then I commit everything and I
just run git tag so at the end I just
like um I run those things and where's
the git and this file is doing the G tag
trainer is just implemented here you're
welcome to look at how I implemented
this whole tag thing it's not very
complicated you just a lot of git
commands and then you take the number at
the end and you figure out so um yeah so
let's check out the monitoring
branch no yeah
yeah so the only element here is
that um I hope it's going to work I
don't want to run it I hope it's just
going to look good and if not you're
welcome to run it later because I don't
think the visualization that I set up
here uh would work also with
the uh no you don't want to open it ah I
know why not here is a great example it
looks at this file it's a it's a heavy
file because of the the images then it's
not materialized it's it's only a
pointer of a place so I'm going to go
here and I do get Z
materialize to that
folder
and Bam well I hope now you can uh at
least be nice and show and kind
of yeah yeah it's okay so this is an
event report I don't know why it's um it
doesn't figure it out but I um in this
place now this is the same rer we talk
about the monitoring I don't have the
data here I only have the monitoring of
all what we saw earlier the running when
I did demo latest you saw all the
predictions I just have those and the ml
runs which I got from all different
experiments that are sitting here maybe
it's a good example of how it looks like
um you have some data sets but let's
look uh this is in run and you have a
parameters and like every other element
is relevant is here and for for some
reason each one of them is kind of a
value as a file but um I I bet it works
very well for distributed stuff but
again it made a bug for my system so
that's not really nice um and again when
I log the model it also is the model
here not in this case but I hope in some
other places the data set was using and
so on so it's a bit of an overhead but
it it works so how would the monitoring
look like and it's just a cool example
uh of using
evidently no are you you can't hand it
anymore okay it's class too
heavy okay so in this case we can see H
well I made I added some noise to get
some something cool because I didn't
want to simulate it uh during the demo I
see they have three minutes left so here
is an example this is how I can keep up
on like which distribution I can see the
prediction is drifted a bit from what it
should be so I can make an alert I can
just get this Json and implemented go to
the Lambda and send the slack message or
whatever and figure it out so you could
just implement it with a few lines but
but the important part is you have all
the information next to you you don't
need to get to it it's just here because
wherever that branch is running you can
get pool and you're going to get the
latest version of that models and the
same thing is also going to be relevant
for the analysis
Branch um is there any
changes
no
yeah no did I save it on a different
place yeah it's on
analysis and here the same kind of
concept I can have the data that I was
using for the training I have it
available for me here because I can and
this is kind of a nice sharp evaluation
of the model and I can take any model
straight from the branch it was sitting
on read it here kind of compare it build
it see how it does get the result and go
oh this model thinks that sex is really
it's really helping you for uh for your
result and um what is here the BMI is
really bad for you and so on so I can do
the analysis and all the information in
one place to manage the entire project
so um I use all the time I at the
beginning I thought maybe an hour and a
half is not enough but I feel like we
kind of uh we managed
so um can
you yeah so this is a summary of
everything we went through so we we went
through all of these different elements
I know it was very technical I know it
was very complicated and this is kind of
like a noan movie I hope in a way that
you rewatch and find new things you that
are useful for you later I don't expect
everyone to get everything in one go uh
but everything within its own context is
actually not that complicated there's no
very difficult aspect of it but there
just a lot of things to do in our field
so again you always upload to Raw you
can do the splits early on you can from
here move corrupted and bad files to a
different place so no one will have to
deal with them besides the people who
deal with the Automation and then you
develop on kind of feature branches like
the dev Baseline the dev linear
regression you can keep data with within
intermediary results and other kind of
pre-processing elements you keep them
all you put them back into your Dev
model or just Dev depends how many
different solutions you have that you
want to solve in the same project and
then at every training I always like to
tag it when I'm happy with it so I also
tag so I can always go back and see
what's going on I move it to prod and
when I'm prod I'm tagging it and that is
the one that can I can deploy later
and now the results of that uh of the
monitoring data is going to the
monitoring Branch when I was training it
I uploaded the uh model tracking you
don't have to um you don't have to use a
single one you might want to have a
different one for tracking for
monitoring but for this one I did it the
same one and uh and again I develop on a
Dev monitoring and merg it into
monitoring and the analysis I actually
feel a bit comfortable just write in
code cuz it just notebooks and stuff
like that at this case now I left you no
time for questions but I do have a slide
for questions um so if there are any and
if you give me the time then we can do
it otherwise uh the mic goes back to
you thank you
Claude uh wonderful uh it was really
really amazing workshop and I'm very
happy that that will have a recording of
that and uh you will be able to get back
and just uh dig deeper uh yeah so
actually we have some some time for for
questions uh if there is any question we
still can use like couple more minutes
to uh yeah to
discuss sure that's what I'm here
for also if you will have some questions
after please remember about slack so you
can definitely ask some questions on the
this uh this event slack um this this
this one for all and um yeah I I saw
that uh yonathan your your mentoring
sessions are already booked uh you have
booked all all the mentoring sessions so
uh I hope that you will have a great uh
great time there and u i I know that you
will be very helpful for for for the and
so and that's that's
awesome so for the questions going
once going twice yeah I don't think many
people can survive an hour and a half of
this kind of intensity in material and
um also it's very hard next to all of
these AI generated uh typos to kind of
concentrate
but I I don't I don't use AI without
iPods it's not my style and Ms helps a
lot uh to concentrate So yeah thank
thank you for doing uh thank you for
doing that um the recording will be
available uh perhaps on YouTube and you
definitely will get a email on that and
uh yeah please please use slack for for
questions and thank you so much and see
you on the next session thank you cheers
bye-bye cheers byebye